seize salles de classe deux cours de
récréation et une bibliothèque
le nouveau groupe scolaire de saint cyr
l'école a fait sa première rentrée en
même temps que les élèves
cette école en travaux depuis un an et
demi marque une étape importante une
nouveau quartier charles renard en
chantier depuis 2008
c'est un peu le une des première
inauguration phare puisqu'on a livré des
premiers logements on a déjà travaillé
sur des mises en état des soldes et des
préparations terrain mais vraiment la
livraison des espaces publics et des
équipements publics c'est vraiment
l'accent incarne la vie du projet est le
vrai démarrage et que les habitants
peuvent voir comment comment ce quartier
prend vie la construction de l'école
jacqueline de romilly financé par grand
paris aménagement a coûté plus de 11
millions d'euros
le bâtiment a été pensé de manière
moderne et épuré
c'est sur l'écriture donc c'est
l'apprentissage de l'écriture donc d'où
cette façade
d'où cette façade composée de lettres et
après à l'intérieur une simplicité
lecture du matériau qui permet de voir
la de de l'irl architecture de façon
simple
efficace qu elle s'intègre parfaitement
dans cet environnement on ne pouvait pas
comme dans d'autres bâtiments de la
ville construira la mansart il était
indispensable de se projeter dans le 21e
siècle et je crois que l'architecturé
extérieure et s'y prête tout à fait plus
de 300 élèves de maternelle et de
primaire sont scolarisés depuis le 4
septembre à terme l'établissement
devrait en accueillir plus de 400
[Musique]